But
stop,
let me tell you that God,
God is right.
There's Black Mitchell.
I know there are still people who hate gays.
Cut the hair,
cut the hair,
protect,
cut,
knit.
Not my house,
Let's Christmas.
Ah,
No,
my house.
But if you are bisexual,
yes,
but I love women.
Oh,
pussy of your Mother,
ass,
send to Chile,
of course they send to Chile,
shell of your mother,
the egg,
dumb dog,
but I'm,
boludo,
send me to Argentina,
Of course,
of course I rule in Argentina,
Who,
echele que le eche,
who, hear,
hear.
Y. And herd,
Peru?
Many people say,
I don't know,
but you may ask,
Hey, hey,
you home,
really.
Hel,
Hell,
yeah,
the Hundred to friends,
oops,
Maxi,
all Craig,
my ska Hogwarts,
no, there,
no,
no to Paul Chepen,
bayukinask.